welcome back to piers morgan on sensor
now donald trump is a man he's used to
winning but he categorically did not win
the 2020 election he lost joe biden won
and trump's been a really really sore
loser ever since
i also believe his refusal to admit
defeat inspired and perhaps incited a
violent mob to descend on the u.s
capitol on january 6 2021 some of the
most shocking scenes american democracy
has ever witnessed
i was appalled by these scenes and i've
always felt that trump should have taken
more responsibility for what was
unequivocally an attempt to prevent the
peaceful handover of power after a
democratic election here's what i said
at the time
he didn't just cross a line he trampled
all over that line and he's now a threat
to american democracy and to those who
warned this was what was going to happen
with trump you've been proven right
i stand by that and i put it directly to
the former president
the things i'm not happy about with the
presidency i'll be completely straight
with you to your face
one of them is what happened on january
6th which was a result of you refusing
to accept the result of the election
before you start this
nancy pelosi is in charge of security
she didn't do her job she's half in
charge of it so the republicans
the mayor of dc and nancy pelosi are in
charge actually republicans and the
democrats have 50 50. but she was
actually cowering for terror in fear of
her life that day because there was a
huge mob of people if she were attacking
the the center of democracy in america i
want to read you what mitch mcconnell
said he's the senate minority well mitch
mcconnell is
not a good representative you can
respond to what he said but he still
remains party he remains he remains the
senior republican unfortunately okay but
he is right now we'll see what happens
okay fair enough
but he said this he's acknowledged that
joe biden was the legitimate winner of
the 2020 election he's rejected your
claims of fraud and he said about
january the 6th we're all there we saw
what happened it was a violent
insurrection for the purpose of trying
to prevent the peaceful transfer of
power after a legitimately certified
election from one administration to the
next that's what it was he told mr the
senate on february the 13th last year
former president trump's actions
preceding the riots were a disgraceful
dereliction of duty he then said that
were achieved there's no question that
president trump is practically and
morally responsible for provoking the
events of that day and even this he said
about the rioters they did this because
they've been fed wild falsehoods by the
most powerful man on earth because he
was angry he'd lost an election
number one
he knew nothing about what took place in
the election the press hates to write
about it but that election was rigged
and it was stolen you said to me 100
i don't mean a little bit and you know
it's funny when a hillary clinton or
when uh stacey abrams says oh the
election was rigged nobody says anything
but when trump says it but the
difference is i have proof
and we have
massive proof okay but let me know all
you have to do is take a look let me ask
you take a look at the ballot harvesting
that took place let me ask you this
millions you said to me once that if you
talk the talk and you're a great talker
i've seen that today if you talk the
talk you have to walk the walk in the
context of your claim about the fortune
election it's been 14 months
and we've not seen this hard evidence of
the fraud that you say happened the
press won't report it the press
this is like a communist country worth
it's all over the place we have not read
everything just put another thing to you
because i've watched this whole debate
rage and you've been completely
unflagging in your refusal to accept
defeat you know why though you know why
because if our country doesn't have
fair and free elections and if our
country doesn't have borders we don't
have a country okay we have crooked
corrupt elections here's what i was
saying and i've proven it is what i
would say to you i believe it was a free
and fair election and that you lost you
don't really believe that's my belief
well then you're a fool however then
you're a fan maybe i am the full i'd be
on the fool in in this conversation
you're a fool and you haven't studied
okay i have studied it
well maybe i am a fool but of course
i've studied it i've read a lot about
what happened with the 2020 election
and i see no hard evidence like i told
him that there was substantial voter
fraud nobody has seen that
but the bottom line with all this is
trump seems to me to be fighting on the
wrong hill about why he was treated
unfairly in 2020. there's another
argument that he could produce which i
think is a lot more merit just three
weeks before the election the new york
post published a sensational front page
story about hunter biden son of a now
president joe biden emails found on
hunter's abandoned laptop contained
proof that he sold influence while his
father was vice president
but the liberal-run social media giants
squashed the scandal with twitter and
facebook shamefully blocking the post
scoop they even stopped the post having
an account
a mainstream media dismissed it all as
russian disinformation so none of them
reported it properly and some believe
that if they had done it could have
swung the election in trump's favor in
other words if more people had known
about this story if more people had
scrutinized this story if it hadn't been
so wrongly censored
then they might have voted differently
or stayed at home i put this to
president trump
there is another twist in this tale
where i think you're on much stronger
ground and where i would agree with you
and that is the suppression of the
hunter biden laptop scandal which is
what it's become and it could lead right
to the top with joe biden we don't know
yet but it seems to me that the way that
mainstream media and the tech giants
conspired to suppress that story
literally removing it from social media
platform 17 not reporting it not chasing
it 50 senior people coming out saying
this was russian disinformation all
complete nonsense
there is a belief that that could have
swung the election your way in other
words
when you talk about having a stolen
election actually you're on better
ground it seems to me with the hunter
are you ready i'm sorry they say it made
a 17-point difference but you know what
even without that
i want it and we want it big and we want
it easily it was so corrupt and it was
so corrupt in wisconsin
that they're saying what do we do they
don't know what to do they caught them
so
only a fool
and i guess you're a fool only a fool
would think that was a legitimate do you
think i'm available
i do now yeah frank sinatra said the
best revenge is massive success
isn't your best revenge rather than
talking constantly about the last i
don't talk constantly but you brought it
up i didn't you did you brought it up
excuse me you brought it up i didn't i
don't talk about it very much i do say
it was rigged mitch mcconnell
is
stupid
and he shouldn't have allowed it to
happen but he did
but if you look at the results and if
you look at what happened
but even you sitting here saying well
that doesn't matter but the law i think
the lawyers look i think the law is even
the numbers your own vice president mike
pence
says you lost the election mike was the
head of the republican party
he says you lost it mike was foolish and
he was weak